we went through all of your comments in
the previous video and picked out the
weirdest combinations now we're going to
eat them
[Music]
I've never dumped a chocolate chip
cookie and sometimes you see looks wrong
oh you went deep girl hey loved it
honestly it's what's weird is both of
these foods are sort of so middle of the
line that this tastes bland and tastes
like somebody dropped a bag of salt into
a cookie mix the savory like the
cheesiness the salty and the sweet is
actually kind of good which I'm
disturbed by it smells like I'm putting
steaks all the seasoning on watermelon
it smells like an old attic thank you
Cheers
[Music]
like that it's like everything at your
backyard barbecue like the barbecue
chicken and why not uh what what a
hellscape have you brought us to the
salt makes you thirsty
remember water mom quenches your thirst
it tastes like I just swallowed the
ocean wait do we like sip it through a
straw actually suddenly this is way more
exciting it's funny to taste spicy
things through a sweet thing like a
spicy soy sauce with like a fruit
roll-up mashed up into it together it
tastes like vile like the spicy tangy
part is like the kitchen vomit
[Music]
how dare you make a Zee bananas in mail
again I'm thinking about the last time I
ate this so salty I'm so sad right now
it was so bad
nope nope there's a little dab of
mayonnaise that makes me hate myself
it's like oatmeal it's all mushed in
your mouth but this I don't know it's
like sweet another there's no flavor but
evil I don't think it's evil I just
think it's a little desperate this is
literally like like a three-year-old was
able to make his lunch hell yeah yeah
mm-hmm
come over to my house every day I'm into
this one is she good day definitely it's
like a smoky peanut butter they're both
kind of like dry tastes yeah
the Bologna isn't too sweet mm-hmm
there's no weird texture
people are jelly no that was so 2014
this is the year of peanut butter and
bologna I would vote for that peanut
burn Bologna 2k16 right I'm having the
best day